TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this week I'm coming to
you from Sydney, Australia.
Here's your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We're making it even
easier to download
early preview builds of Android
Studio with a new website.
If you loved trying out all of
the newest features in Android
Studio and helping us
make it a better IDE,
it's the place for you.
The link is in the
description below.
This post outlines some cool
resources for building games
with actions on Google.
They include a new sound effect
library and a handy guide
for bringing text adventures to
life for Google Assistant users
on Google Home.
There's a new website for Google
Open Source that ties together
all of our initiatives
with information
on how we use, release,
and support open source.
Check it out at
opensource.google.com.
We recently released AudioSet,
a collection of over 2
million 10-second
YouTube excerpts
labeled with a vocabulary of
527 sound event categories,
with at least 100 examples
for each category.
If you're doing audio research
with machine learning,
this is for you.
Details and links
are on the post.
If you use Firebase
Cloud Messaging,
updates to background process
optimizations in Android O
might affect you.
Check out this post for
some quick details and code.
Google App Engine
flexible environment
is now available
in the Europe-West
It's our first new
region since going GA.
The steps to get
started are on the post.
Dynamic search
ads help you reach
people who are searching for
your products and services
without the need for
you to actively manage
keywords or ads.
We're introducing three
improvements to them--
page feeds, expanded ads,
and quality enhancements.
Details and examples
are on the post.
And it's that time
of year again.
But don't worry if you miss
some of the practical jokes.
We've included the links
to a few of our favorites
in the description below.
Don't forget to like and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode from down under.
If you liked the
episode, remember
to share it with
all of your friends
or check out some of
our previous episodes
over here on the left.